you know  [Music]  one of these bullets is like us  traveling  forward through time the other one's  going backwards  can you tell which is which  how about now  [Music]  why does it feel so strange you're not  shooting the bullet  you're catching it whoa i didn't win  back in my cell felt like hell first  [Applause]  days who's the america he seems nice i  invited him to the dinner  looks good with fists for a diplomat  there are people in the future who need  us  [Music]  you get something i'm not gonna like  time isn't the problem getting out alive  that's a problem  [Music]  when i dance  well i'm going so any tips will be  welcome ain't no time what do you think  we're seeing  the detritus of a coming war  [Music]  you want to crash a plane well how big a  plane  that part is a little dramatic  last time it was no tennis 3d pg-13  you